president trunk doubled down on his
positions on border security and
criticisms of the judicial system he
addressed both topics in a thanksgiving
call with service members we're doing
very well in the southern border we're
very tough we get a lot of bad court
decisions from the Ninth Circuit which
has become a big thorn in our side
always lose and then you lose again and
again and then you hopefully win at the
Supreme Court which we've done but it's
a terrible thing when judges take over
your protective services when they tell
you how to protect your border it's a
disgrace
mr. Trump also defended the private
email use of his daughter Ivanka Trump
and his controversial stance on Saudi
Arabia
Susan pages USA TODAY's Washington
bureau chief good morning Susan
hey good morning Alex so the president
boat broke with tradition in both the
tenor and the content of his
Thanksgiving calls and meetings
yesterday did he not yes he did you know
it is a tradition it's become a
tradition for presidents on Thanksgiving
to either visit troops who are
endangered suti abroad or to call them
but it's usually carefully non-political
it thanks them for he usually thanks
them for their service and for being
keeping us safe even on a holiday like
Thanksgiving that's not the approach
that president Trump took yesterday he
gave basically a political address laced
with grievances talking about his
complaints about the Ninth Circuit
that's something we've also been hearing
from the president on Twitter so quite a
different approach by this president
Susan president Trump again dismissed
the CIA's assessment that Saudi Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman ordered the
death of Jamal Khashoggi where does the
us-saudi relationship go from here it's
business as usual
you know remarkable language the
president used he said the CIA didn't
have a finding that found the crown
prince responsible for that terrible
murder of a Washington Post journalist
said they had a feeling that is not
usually the language that is used for
conclusions and assessments by the CIA
and you know I think there's a question
about where where us-saudi relations go
here the president has clearly
determined to maintain our alliance
without big penalties for the death of
this journalist but there are a lot of
Americans include
some Republicans on Capitol Hill who
disagree with him on that so we'll have
to see how this unfolds and he is also
isolated I think with the view around
the world of other allies that something
more serious needs to happen to punish
Saudi Arabia for this terrible event
Suzan Alex mentioned the president also
defending his daughter and her use of
private email for official government
business is the White House concerned
that this may go a step further now in
Congress may get involved you know it's
possible we have Democrats taking over
the House of Representatives that will
give them the power to try to
investigate exactly what happened with
this now this will maybe raise some
concerns about hypocrisy on all sides
because Democrats of course were very
critical of Republicans for doing what
they said making too much of a big deal
over Hillary Clinton's emails problems
or the controversy over emails but I
think that Ivanka Trump is about to
discover what Hillary Clinton did which
is there will be scrutiny of how she
used and possibly misused a private
email all right Susan page always great
to have you thank you so much hey thank
you